because
yes
everything is
done so no doubt you must have a Creator
and you know what believe in the create
a police creation
is like it's not true however choose our
environment our family is a Jew or a
Christian or a fire worshiper or atheist
because believe in God which is not true
like I said yeah so what is this
place like I said no doubt as a creator
of Jesus knowledge you can see there's
no difference
foreign
[Music]
other religions
I'll tell you you know Islam came to
preserve five things first is yeah Islam
came Reserve practice Islam came to
preserve the religion what does that
means believing in one God is so
important that's why taking example
politicism atheism is forbidden why will
it turn away from God what happens our
own desires and we can see what happens
our society
which is getting crazy so the the most
important one preserving and protecting
the revolution
second one
observing the intellect is the internet
that's when Islam alcohol and drugs is
forbidden
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why Islam interest and gambling
is forbidden yeah interests as well
hopefully Islam came to preserve
marriage family lineage Heritage that's
why fornication adultery is forbidden
lastly Islamic of life that's why
committing suicide kidney people and
Justice foreign
interest is a type of manipulation in
Islam if you are in need of help I
should not utilize your hardship to
manipulate you what I do I can give you
money unless I give it back to me or I
can forgive you Islam teach us about the
Brotherhood rather our Prophet said the
Muslim nation is like a party if any
part of the body feel pain the whole
body feel pain so my brother is that if
you go through hardship it is upon me to
try to help you yeah so so likewise
adultery destroy families all right and
all of these evil vices he goes back to
them like it's evil only turn away from
God
you understand the way from God like I
said because I'm following our own
desires now people are confused they are
men and women
What's Happening Now understand so so
these five things can Preserve
for us individually effectively so why
there are some people hate Islam I heard
about ignorance
money for me they're making a money from
the suffering of the people so because
they are rich the way they do they
utilize their money to make established
through the media and this was happening
the mainstream media Islam look bad but
even though Islam is prove us
individually also we have to think
Gloria how a man Prophet Muhammad
existed 1400 years ago was able to come
with a better trip
when you see interest will become
widespread interesting even if you
aren't involved directly it will affect
you
you know now if you open a bank account
even if you tell the business I don't
want to interest in my bank account I
said yeah that's fine no problem but
they will use your money for interest
yeah
so the question you ask ourselves how a
man that existed 1400 years ago was able
to prophesize about something we can
observe right now because it's a
messenger of the creator
yeah the five universities
stations
except Islam because God who created you
and create everyone he wants good for us
you know with human beings we just need
something always there's evil desires
involved or vice yeah he said but we
understand we're important creative we
should say something it's always good
for everyone except the evil ones who
doesn't want to follow it yeah so if
there's no God everything becomes
objective
if you tell me don't do this I said yeah
it's up to you it's your that's your
opinion but that's why you know there's
a verse in the Quran that's why in the
Western World now and other countries
what's happening we are in the in an era
of subjectivity
you know what's happening now yeah you
think it's wrong to you is wrong to me
it's okay you understand and Allah
mentioned that in the Quran there's a
verse when the prophet Moses was
speaking to Pharaoh so Pharaoh said to
him
who is the road of God that exists so
Moses said
he said the Lord of Moses said to
Pharaoh this verse in the Quran the lord
of the heavens and the earth and the
oceans in between if you have any
certainty the school has mentioned in it
if you don't have no certainty about
your Creator and that it should be worse
alone then you will have no surgery
about nothing else and this is exactly
the outcome of atheism subjectivity
what your answer is you don't understand
creation
the lgbtq or not man is clearly healthy
man but he feels he's a woman Inside he
goes a cut of everything
I'll give you example it doesn't mean
because you feel something you have to
implement it Himachal said you brought
him
I feel I should have borne as an armless
person even though clearly I'm but I
feel no I should be harmless would you
help me to cut off my arms no like
perfect classic would you help me to
come up no
so imagine healthy everything's healthy
but because I feel something I got kind
of no that's right you know that's what
I'm saying but again
mentioned that was gonna happen yeah
Allah mentioned that Satan is going to
inspire people to change Allah's
creation Allah created you in as a man
you want to be a woman as a woman you
want to be a man as a man you want to be
chicken what's going on man so also
there's there's a Hadith Muhammad said
he will come outside
with a woman
sexually then he's not going to another
having sex with another man and when a
woman will not be suffice with the man
she will go to another woman that's
what's happening
again how Amanda exists one thousand
four days ago knew that because he was a
messenger of the coordinator and who
knows everything in details the Creator
what will say to you also we don't
really have no good example that's off
license can you see right there off
license yeah
so someone who sells drugs
Like Cocaine you know something you can
you can sell drugs outside he'll get
arrested and he will be sent to prison
but the offline is a shopkeeper nothing
happened to him even though they sell in
the same they're selling the products
which cause above same half
and it intoxicates people to do evil
things
and it is allowed and the other one who
sells drugs is not allow it that's my
point when you have no code
and Allah mentioned in the Quran women
are rather than decree
from our remembrance will have a
miserable life what we say to you bro
I'm a multi-millionaire
you know I've been having a nice
discussion with you I will I will give
you two million pounds as a gift two
million pounds as a gift what would you
say to me if you do take it
would you remember me all the time of
course two million pounds of big money I
will give you two million pounds on the
condition giving you two eyes
no go why because your eyes is more
valuable than too many people yeah so
why are you not grateful and remember
okay
you know another example I can give you
is what imagine tonight to go to your
house and you wake up in the morning in
your own room there's a fire everywhere
and you try your best to Serve Yourself
you couldn't you gave up before you know
why it's over and I came and I saved
your life what would you say to me thank
you
you know I thank you I'll remember you
all the time but I won't give your life
for free why don't you thank him on
remembering while we're speaking we are
benefiting from the the blessings of
oxygen you know may Allah forbid if you
go to hospitals and we need oxygen they
will charge us but God God's giving it
to you for free the other question I
would ask you if you want to buy a gift
for your mother with
or your mother love
but likewise
I'm gonna be grateful to him you should
wash them the way he loves not the way
we love that's why I send prophets and
messages like Moses Abraham Jesus and
many many and Allah
mentioned
foreign
that's why these books be preserved nor
the Bible to be corrupted because you
don't have it in the original language
so in the Quran Allah said he made it
easy to be memorized that is a claim
so there's two claims that this book
Allah made it easy to be memorized and
this book allows preservatives yes now
if you go to many countries Muslim
countries
Muslims at the age of 9 and 10. and word
forward and letter for letter yes
sometimes you know what they don't even
know the language the Arabic language
we memorize this book in Chinese
but guess what we don't even speak
Chinese
you speak French
tell us it is
Imagine who don't speak the language
yeah but we memorize this book in
Chinese but we don't even speak the
language
but guess what also when it comes to
Quran even we don't know not Arabs we
speak Arabic don't make mistakes in
Arabic but only can support and they
recite it perfectly
also the other challenge that if the
Muslims and the Jews and the Christians
all of them decide to burn scriptures
they know that get rid of our scriptures
the only scripture will remain with us
is the whole act because we memorize
this word forward and later for it so
how a man that exists 1 400 years ago
conveying something from God and we can
see it right now
like I said it's many that's why I
understand it's not based upon dreams or
other dreams is the truth that's what
I'm used to know Islam is based upon
Universal proofs
so as well you know the first thing of
Islam which is
Allah
and according to the teaching of this
prophet Muhammed
so in Islam there's there's a prayer
there's the first pillar which is the
two testimony there's a prayer passive
charity but you know where it's over
Islam whatever Allah has to do is good
for us
intellectually spiritually physically
physically socially economically
likewise whoever Allah Trump has to stay
away from it it's best for us
we're gonna live this life how many
people left the house and never come
back how many people won't sleep they
never wake up you understand that's what
in the Quran Allah challenge the people
with death Allah said
surely will meet you and you will return
to your lord the lord of the sin and the
Unseen and he will inform you of that
which you used to do the almighty has
attributes of mercy and attribute of
anger and of love and hatred and
attribute of of Mighty that's why based
upon mercy and love he created Paradise
based upon Mighty and anger he create
the Hellfire but also it's just he gave
you Free Will and the freedom so and it
shows us the wrong path and the right
path Allah said
to the human being rather is grateful
and grateful
so if it makes sense to you I would
invite you to become a Muslim to accept
Islam how many years you've been cutting
off from your creator
if I saved your life what would you say
to me you thank me you don't even know
who I am I'm the murderer I'm a killer
because I say something is so deep to
you with even have to think about me
anymore what about the world Almighty
has been merciful to you how old are you
by the way 26. you look younger bro who
you've been eating man you have to tell
us so while we say to 26 whenever that
out of starvation God always provides
for you understand you know through your
God is Almighty and Powerful the rain
is a mercy of God but also the same
Reign was contending into his anger by
destroying people with it so you see who
there's there is
my food
why because there's no rape so what we
do money is useless what we do is we
send food so we need rain so of course
they give not strain but the biggest
crime and guess what will it turn away
from him because the Muslim who commits
like fornication is even without others
is evil but it's better than someone who
is not Muslim because why the Muslim is
accepting his creator
is following his creator but it's not
perfect but the one who non-muslim will
turn away from God normally he doesn't
know his ignorance no only then he's
worse you know why because it's
belittling
he said oh God Almighty the creator of
this tremendous creation I don't care
about you I don't believe you deserve to
be worshiped
so that comes and the ability and that
is worse that's why paganism disbelief
atheism is worse than any other since
yeah so you want to become Muslim does
it make sense to you
I can't agree to that now right if he
makes sense you it's clearly makes sense
but you know a lot of a lot of things
not like this let me pray like you have
Christianity go die for your sins
doesn't make any sense how God created
you with the sin and die for yourself
you have Jewish god or the tribal God
understand so like you said you said you
make sense when there's a Creator but
you haven't find a conclusion the
conclusions of Islam
foreign
clear please that's why I said
my wife is a river
she was 14 when she become Muslim girl I
have a friend yes
okay
once we had like eight people become
Muslims here eight yeah yeah but usually
at least one or two becomes because
we're every Friday
and you know there's a mess in the
foreign
not the fastest growing religion on the
face of the earth is Islam
even though there's many barriers
stop it Islam spread but Islam spreading
because Allah promised us
in the standard Smiles bro you know
that's what I'm saying anyone that do
not become Muslim
because of two reasons or two factors
either is a psychological factor or a
social Factor what is psychological
Factor are they you know it's arrogance
or he likes something which is damned to
not do for example maybe he likes to
drink alcohol
he's a person that people look up to I
might accept that Islam is just going to
become a normal guy so you think you
know what I'm not going to become a
Muslim or he's scared that except Islam
his family and guess him see who prefer
his family over his creator understand
but no one can tell me he doesn't accept
Islam because Islam does not make sense
and it's not the truth never because
like I said there's overwhelming why
Islam is the truth
it's done so I want to know what is your
reason for looking at Islam what is my
reason what about these guys
like what is it if you make sense
because in love with reality I think it
just comes down to the concrete group
you know every religion
they can't give you enough I'm telling
you okay let's go back step by step yeah
all right okay the problem is that I
told you Prophet Muhammad mentioned
not random there's difficult prediction
prediction but there is a science you
can see something's gonna happen you
know okay prophecies
the outside reality is good and guess
what you're going to prophesy
there's not any sign that's why prophecy
is so powerful you know so what I'm
saying to you how we knew that there's
many policies also why he's the only man
who came with his perfect way of life
the five Universal Necessities also
about you know what they call it
worshiping God Alone even the Quran
Allah himself in a perfect way the
Oneness of God in Islam is so pure you
know we're allowed to boundaries
Allah directly when you come to
Christianity you have to go through
Jesus no Islam you have to go for No One
You Preach Allah director yes we pray
according to the teaching of prophet
Muhammad
Allah
you know why it makes sense of creation
because the way this guy himself
it makes sense he's the creator of his
creation but when it comes to the Bible
the Old Testament
God regrets that's not the nature of God
regrets when you don't know the outcome
of something book The Bible the deadly
Testament of constitution God become a
baby
but Almighty become created
doesn't make any sense for God created
with sin but you're a baby how created
with sin
we believe that babies is being born
here they're okay with sin instead so my
point here is when you analyze Islam
with other religions the only ocean
makes sense this time
Christians I had a dream
I never told you I dream I never told my
personal experience even to have my
personal experience what is the same is
the truth that's my personal experience
but I'm gonna use it with you I gave you
a universal boost
you can see it like for example another
prophecy Prophet Muhammad said he will
come outside when you see the Barefoot
Arab man competing in building Soul
buildings
competing in building tour buildings
in the middle of nowhere that Dubai and
Saudi 50 years ago is a pure desert let
alone 1 000 400 years ago
and competing with one another let me
ask you where is the tallest building in
the world
how we knew that
that's what I'm saying bro it's so
concrete Baba like Quran why we have
many books claimed to be from God has
not been preserved the only Quran why in
this book it says Allah made it easy to
be memorized and we can go we can go
YouTube like in our mosque you know like
no more rice I have my children memories
and word for word not all of it yeah you
think without without Islam
because
human beings God create us to know what
is right or as long in general but in
details Islam video God you create up
you understand
it's impossible to live a good way that
is your creator yeah
yes yes understand
but you want to have your uncle
curriculum
you'll be confused more than
confused.com
in the start so become a servant of your
creator of worshiping the Lord and only
way to worship your creator give you
everything is by following instead of
teaching and by the way I believe in
Jesus I believe he was a Muslim
because why is a Muslim Muslim doesn't
mean you have to become an Arab when you
become Pakistan you actually now Muslim
me to worship God Alone
submission to God alone and to free
yourself from paganism and his people
understand to be understand the purpose
of your of your uh why you created you
understand your own existence by the
virtue of your creator
you want to be grateful to him
who has given you yes
giving you eyes I'll give you I'll give
you two million pounds for your eyes he
says no
you see okay give it to you for free
give your life for free oxygenated you
know everything for free why you want
you to watch a lot you know on a day of
judgment Allah will say to the
disbeliever if if I give you 10 times of
This World
would you sacrifice it today to serve
yourself from the punishment of the fire
you say my Lord no doubt I will do it
Allah will say to him I ask you less
than that I ask you to worship me alone
I shall not associate any partner with
me by your rejecting it's too late now
you know there's a Satan remember Satan
churches with our creator
it's done
you know
so that's my advice to you I would love
you to become Muslim I'm not going to
force you something but it's
encouragement if it makes sense and it's
true and they say no it makes sense man
it's so clear I'm always I'm always
happy to hear yeah
otherwise
[Laughter]
you know but you know like I said
everything has a method extreme
and some people they're too close you
know that's why
the best path is the middle part you're
happy medium yeah in the middle path
it's done if you have any questions that
you want to ask you heard about Islam
something you can ask any questions
that's what we're here for to answer
these questions misconception a doubt
what you said
space from San Francisco
wishes
they should have guidance there's
guidance which I convey the magician as
for changing your heart
there's some people I've been doing this
for years
there's some people are spoken for maybe
10 minutes
but something you have to understand
that we can live you can die anytime
nothing is guaranteed except them so God
put you here as a test for you so if you
die and you don't accept Islam you don't
blame no one except yourself
like when you're talking about the other
religions the other religions
Christianity Jesus never claims and
Christians
Judaism
all of them submit to God Alone in the
stand so that's what I'll say to your
city when we say all the prophets and
messages
you know even there's in that leaflet
there is a quote from a non-believers
speaking of prophet Muhammad
the way of life he came with
you know
there's there's legislation how to
respond this legislation how to deal
with your parents how to deal with your
wife how to deal with your children how
do your enemies with your neighbors with
the environment they know what time
before the time of Peace everything you
know not if I want to have a country
in order to run the country I mean what
ministers
minister of economy minister of war
minister of this year I kind of come
with all rules
the Islamic empire one of the best
empire ever existed
all the Islamic empire is based upon one
man's future
because remember like I said if I want
to run a country I have to have expected
everything I can't be expect everything
never happened except the prophets of
God
who couldn't read and write as well
he lived in the middle of desert coming
wood is a perfect way of life and
guideline in every aspect of life
because he came from the almighty Allah
let me give you some examples during his
lifetime eclipse happened yeah and
eclipse happened at the same day when
his son passed away yeah so his
followers were not familiar with Eclipse
they say oh the reason is Eclipse
because Prophet Muhammad passed away
yeah
look what happened because remember a
liar will tried to utilize any
opportunity to manipulate the people but
what he said he said no that a case has
nothing to do with no one's life
everyone's death that's from God when
you see it that's the prayer well he did
and never connected to himself he
connects them to God that's not the
nature of a lion likewise through his
lifetime his friend was married to this
woman he loved her so much all right and
he was following her around but she
wants a divorce
so the messenger foreign
of course
I'll be a believer
no no you can't you can't read the Quran
you can read everything here
I don't know the problem is you yeah
yeah so be honest like what is that if
you make sense
like this proves that these prophecies
and a little
and so on
to overwhelm it for for a man to be just
normal guy
we are in need of God
they will worship God not because God is
not because God is in need of our
worship because we are in need of
worshiping God
you know if we don't know worship God
will be like a fish out of water
for the fish to be alive to be inside
the water so the people that's why
Prophet Muhammad said the one that
worship God and the waters on the
worship God is like a dead and a life
how many people are walking but like
if your hearts after you for your heart
to be alive
there's no bits of life for your heart
and my heart
is safe to connect it to you
it's creator
and that's what I'm saying so
I've advised to become Muslim it makes
sense to you play that's what I thought
it makes sense and they believe you know
we'll explain I believe it's less
overwhelming pools that Prophet Muhammad
is this man is a prophet of God he slept
this version of God
that's step by step you know you kind of
accept you cannot stop everything
the example I would always give is like
a king if you have a big cake front of
you and you eat all of it at once what
will happen
in order for you to feel the sweetness
of the cake yeah
that's what I'm doing here today yeah
that's the first Foundation
Islam because if you accept Islam and
you leave
all you see is Forgiven
Paradise except you have a date you have
to pay it off no doubt but if you live
as a Muslim and may Allah forbid if you
do that power that away in the
stand and of course you want to learn
more dogs if you want to drive a car if
you want to learn how to drive a car do
you run outside the car or inside the
car inside the car you're the king and
that kid is the cutest
which is
I've been witness there's no one worthy
of motion
amid the messenger of Allah then you
open you turn on the card and you
started
that's when you open the door of Islam
and your friend already Muslim yeah I
can help you
to learn more
of course
if you make sense it's clear to you are
you guys tomorrow
but you know I want to know what is that
if there's anybody that's stopping you
maybe I can help you why does it make
sense I agree with the principles yeah
that's what I agree with
um I still don't look super easy
yeah
get me the knife
[Laughter]
I mean every Friday yeah
um
every Friday here